[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out Pro and after making
videos ranking the entire demon clan and
the entire goddess clan from weakest to
strongest a large number of you guys
asked me to do the same for some of the
other clans including the fairies so in
this video I will be giving the people
what they want and I will be giving you
all of the important information about
the fairy clan / race while also ranking
all the known fairies from weakest to
strongest if you have suggestions for
future videos feel free to leave them
down in the comments if you enjoy this
type of content and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell before we get started
I want to announce that we are
organizing our create your own original
seven deadly sins character contest we
already organized similar contests in
the past for both my hero academia and
attack on Titan and they were a huge
success so we're doing it again for the
seven deadly sins all you have to do is
submit your original character idea by
following us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar and replying to the
relevant thread I will link the thread
in the description and in the pinned
comments so just click there and submit
your ideas it is a 200 word maximum
please remember that because sometimes
we get over a thousand submissions and
we have to read them all so please no
more than 200 words in your submission
please include the character's name a
brief backstory and their special powers
/ abilities you can make the character a
member of whichever clan or race you
want but bonus points if you create a
completely new clan / race for that
character that doesn't even exist in the
seven deadly sins as of right now the
winning character will be brought to
life by Pro manga artist Cuusoo Mari
just like he did for the previous two
contests you have until the end of the
year to enter and the winner will be
decided live on our twitch channel so be
sure to follow us on twitch link in the
description and in the pinned comment
now let's do this
members of the fairy race have a
childlike appearance pointy ears and
wings although some fairies do not grow
wings until much later in life and this
includes both King and Elaine who are
considered to be late bloomers fairies
are closely connected to nature and
thanks to the power of
the sacred tree the fairies have the
ability to control nature for example
King does this when he uses his spirit
spear chasta for fairies can fly or
levitate and they tend to live much
longer than humans between a thousand
and fifteen hundred years they also
never get sick they don't need a lot of
sleep and their bodies do not decompose
after death they have the ability to
transform their bodies to look like
humans as we've seen both with King and
with halgrim in the human world fairy
wings are thought to have magical
healing properties and for this reason
the wings of a fairy can fetch a high
price as a result fairies have sometimes
been killed by humans for their wings
each fairy smells like a specific flower
or herb and even though the fairies have
extremely strong magical abilities they
tend to be very weak physically which is
part of the reason why humans were able
to trick and overpower them in the past
of course in order to make this list as
up-to-date as possible we have to get
into some manga spoilers so proceed with
caution
you have been warned in terms of the
ranking first up we have the regular
fairies which are fairies that we see
flying around and communicating with the
other characters but we don't see them
do very much fighting so we can assume
that they are the weakest members of the
fairy clan most of these fairies are
such minor characters that they are not
even named in the series but we do know
the names of some of them including end
day and dwara after that we have the
invisible fairy that shows itself only
to death fears and uses her ability to
be invisible to secretly gather
information on his behalf
death Pierce used her to spy on the 10
commandments for him and since this is
the only fairy that is depicted as being
able to turn invisible in the series we
can assume that this ability is unique
to her for this reason I would rank her
above the regular fairies since her
ability for stealth obviously gives her
a clear advantage but since we never see
her engaging in any sort of combat I
wouldn't be comfortable ranking her any
higher than that next up one of the
first fairies whose combat capabilities
we see to a significant degree is of
course hell Brom Kings best friends from
childhood hell Brom is one of the
strangest characters in the seven deadly
sins as he goes from being a fairy to
pretending to be a human to pretending
to be a talking helmet then he goes back
to pretending to be a human then after
that he goes
to being a fairy then it turns out that
he's actually a zombie fairy that he
dies that he becomes a zombie fairy
again and finally he becomes a ghost
fairy but to make his complicated life
story short he was once a kind natured
fairy who out of curiosity about humans
and their culture left the fairy Kings
forest with some fellow fairies and
ventured into the human realm
the fairies came across some human
merchants but instead of teaching them
about human culture the humans tricked
the fairies and started ripping off
their wings because as I mentioned
earlier fairy wings are believed to have
priceless medicinal properties so they
are worth a fortune to humans feeling
angry and betrayed hell Brom killed a
human named Aldridge and assumed his
identity using his fairy ability to
transform in order to make himself look
exactly like Aldridge at this point
Halperin became a genocidal maniac bent
on killing all the humans but he was
eventually stopped and killed by King
but of course that wasn't the end for
our boy hell Brom and he was eventually
brought back to life as some sort of
fairy zombie by Hendrickson
he was eventually killed again then
brought back to life again by
Hendrickson and then killed yet again at
which point his soul started possessing
his helmet and in that state he was able
to communicate with King whenever he
wears the helmet he'll broom appears
pretty early on in the story and his
power is believed to be compatible with
data what great holy night his combat
class was measured at 1,400 and the
other characters who will appear on this
list surpass him significantly as the
story progresses but keeping in mind
he'll Burma's stubborn ability to keep
coming back from the dead over and over
again I certainly wouldn't underestimate
him next up is Gerhard a the sister of
the first fairy King gloxinia yet had
that serves as an advisor to the fairy
king and she is a stern and committed
defender of the fairy clan she actually
took part in the previous holy war which
means that she somehow managed to stay
alive for more than 3,000 years even
though fairies are not supposed to live
that long and over the course of the
story she was shown to be an extremely
capable fighter as she is able to fight
effectively against bond during the
Albion arc and she is also shown to be
capable of taking out lesser demons such
as the orange demon in the later arcs
her highest power level has been
measured at two thousand three hundred
and seventy then we have Elaine King's
sister and the former defender of the
you as the protector of the fountain and
the fairy Kings forest during Kings
absence she was said to be able to
defeat an entire army of holy Knights on
her own and this is before her wings
finally growing fully since her and her
brother King are both late bloomers
before the wings grow in her power level
was measured at two thousand eight
hundred and thirty but once her wings do
grow in fully during the current arc
Alain's power level jumps to a far
higher twenty-one thousand fifty and she
is able to save bond from Alaska 'la one
of the ten commandments although she had
help from Elizabeth and others in doing
this it was said that Elaine's feelings
for bond the one she loves make her body
stronger as everyone who is caught up to
the manga knows Elaine is another
character who is able to die and come
back to life over and over again during
the course of the story and when you
combine that with her powerful love for
bond which gives her additional strength
it is clear that Elaine is definitely a
character whose power during key moments
in the story cannot be underestimated
next up is the second fairy King Dahlia
now in our world the named Dahlia
appears in multiple cultures and
languages and as far as I am aware it is
almost always a female name but Dahlia
is referred to as the previous fairy
King and the second fairy king so it is
possible that in the world of Nana to no
taizai Dahlia is a male name otherwise I
would think that Dahlia would have been
called the fairy queen rather than king
unfortunately we know next to nothing
about Dahlia other than the fact that he
was one of the fairy Kings and that he
was greatly respected by Harlequin and
King was likely greatly influenced and
inspired by Dahlia this leads me to
assume that Dahlia as a former fairy
king was stronger than all the fairies
that we have mentioned up to this point
although we cannot know for sure since
we have no specific information about
Dahlia in any of the canonical material
and of course that means that we have
nothing resembling a combat class or
power level for Dahlia now this image
from the 2015 7 Deadly Sins nintendo 3ds
game has been circulating around the
internet and a number of people have
claimed that this image shows the second
fairy queen Dahlia apparently this image
reveals that Dahlia is a blond female
fairy which would make her a fairy queen
rather than King some have also pointed
out that the
Fairey in this image looks a lot like a
lane and that she may actually be the
mother of a lane and king however others
have argued that the previous game isn't
necessarily canon and the other issue
here is that the female fairy in this
image does not have large fairy wings
and we know that male Yoda's previously
stated that unlike Harlequin at the
beginning of the series both of the
former fairy Kings gloxinia and Dahlia
had large fully grown wings but let me
know what you guys think about this one
was King's predecessor a king or a queen
and was he or she somehow related to
King and Elaine leave your thoughts in
the comments below and that brings us to
the first fairy King gloxinia gloxinia
is a fourteen hundred year old fairy and
the former king of the fairy Kings
forest during the previous holy war he
decided to align himself with the demon
clan as a result of a personal tragedy
that he experienced and for which he
blamed the humans and their allies he
eventually became one of the demon clans
elite warriors as he took on the role as
one of the ten commandments that green
octopus that we see surrounding him when
he is first introduced is in fact the
spirits beer boss kiosk which is the
special weapon that he had been granted
as the fairy king just like King spirits
beer Shasta full basquiat can take on
many different forms including the
formal a green octopus consistent with
his fairy background gloxinia has great
magical power but not much physical
strength like King gloxinia possesses
the ability known as disaster which
allows him to control nature through the
use of his spirit spear stemming from
his ability to control nature gloxinia
can create various monsters from the
earth and used them for his own ends and
this is on top of the many other
abilities that he possesses there relate
in some way to nature and earth
manipulation gloxinia highest recorded
power level was an impressive 50,000
although it should be noted that the
vast majority of that came from his
magic ability and virtually none of it
came from his physical strength and
finally we have the strongest member of
the fairy clan that we have seen to date
the current fairy king Harlequin after
his wings finally grow out fully
although he is easily one of the weakest
characters in the entire series when it
comes to pure physical strength as a
fairy King possesses enormous magical
power
and we know that during the mass of
Esther OSA / mild battle in the manga
King awakens his full potential and
attains a new form in this form his
fairy wings finally grow to their full
size and also his hairstyle goes full
Alvis for some reason fun fact
Elvis was often called the king of rock
and roll or just the king so I think the
fact that King's new hairstyle resembles
the hairstyle of Elvis may not be a
coincidence it could actually be a
direct reference to the king of rock and
roll
at any rate Kings highest recorded power
level was 40 1600 but this was long
before he attained his new form as the
fairy king of rock and roll in this form
he is able to hear the hearts of those
around him essentially reading their
minds including their innermost thoughts
and by using his true chest aful and its
many forms he is able to easily defeat
mile in his corrupted form even though
so many others including Golder sorry el
tauriel and derriere 'i couldn't do
anything to him in my opinion this new
form has elevated King to one of the
strongest characters in the entire
series and I think that he is now easily
the strongest known member of the fairy
clan unless we get some brand new fairy
characters being introduced in the
future like maybe the former fairy king
Dahlia and unless it turns out that they
are insanely strong King will remain the
absolute strongest fairy in the series
for the foreseeable future and although
his current power level or combat class
has not been accurately measured it is
very possible that Kings current power
level may be well over 200,000 and that
is it every known member of the fairy
clan ranked from weakest to strongest if
you enjoy the stuff of content and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell don't forget
to enter to create your own seven deadly
sins character contest by following us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime out
drawer the direct links to the threads
will be in the description and
independence so be sure to check that
out and please only one entry per person
also be sure to follow us on twitch
twitch TV slash anime uproar so that you
can tune in when we decide the winner of
the contest live as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]
you